women marry men  hoping  they change and they don't  men marry women hoping they stay the  same and they don't okay woman change  man stays the same unless if a man  allows a woman to change them  into who he is now today because now  you're scared you're walking on  eggshells and when a man is in that web  they rarely know they're in that web and  they get destroyed they do they lose  their dna and eventually you're in so  deep that you're convinced  you're supposed to be this person it's  treacherous to be in that situation i  think there's only one thing he can do  if he announced tomorrow  that he's found divorce and he's sick of  it hey love you we had a good run but i  gotta move on and i gotta go live my  life  i will tell you three six twelve months  later everything about his reputation  would would change and people would say  finally he's standing up for himself